[Musique]
d'où ces éducateurs donc c'est quoi
pierru kindle y'a plus personne nulle
part oui monsieur
six mois tel permis à la conduite
accompagnée
c'était quoi que tu en sais pas mais ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'on n'est pas à lui
mettre des couteaux
[Musique]
maman kkb d'où vous avez vu quelqu'un tu
crois que c'est quoi pierru king est
salut c'est comme ça partout dans toute
la ville y'a plus personne il part oui
monsieur si lointain
mustang gt500 shelby 1967 mantel permis
au moins là vous dites accompagner
gr
c'était quoi [ __ ] j'ai pas mais ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'on n'est pas seul aux
manettes on va partir à quitter la ville
je vais pas sur dramatiser mais j'ai
jamais vu un truc pareil
le brouillard est de plus en plus proche
peut pas rester là ça me rappelle une bd
crise et quand j'étais petit est vrai un
perso il ressemble vachement lui mettre
des couteaux
on n'est pas ensemble on n'arrivera pas
[Musique]